so for those of us breaking toxic family cycles
have you heard the phrase
I hope your kid is just like you now
I didn't hear this
my scapegoat older sister heard this her whole life
and actually
when I had my first born
I had it said about my daughter because she
my daughter was very similar and still is to my older sister like oh no
she's just like Sarah
using my sister as
like the negative comparison
and you know what I realized through all this
it's actually really messed up
I love my daughter
and I realised my reactions to her behaviour were something I had to fix
and I have re parented myself
and I'm still in the process of re parenting myself and becoming a respectful
gentle parent for her
so all of that comparison only showed me
that my parents weren't willing or able to do the work required for my sister
and that was the failing of a parent not a kid